plus que quelques heures avant le jour j
ça fait longtemps qu'on attend c'est
puis on est en train de tout préparé
pour que ce soit la meilleure ouverture
pas ça arrive au bon moment je vous dit
elle
par contre c'est sûr qu'on doit
recommencer haut niveau le d'équipé du
seuil beaucoup de travail à faire
ce restaurant ne sera ouvert que cinq
jours par semaine puisqu'il manque
d'employés en cuisine résultats de la
pandémie
de plus en plus aux paires d'ailés les
employés donc nos équipes notre équipe
nous nous donner le re aura un leur
démission parce que changer de métier de
domaines mais elle l'a échappé belle
elle pourra rouvrir d'autres n'ont tout
simplement pas survécu dont le grumman
le populaire restaurant de tacos de
saint henri a été forcé de fermer en
octobre dernier son mythique camions de
rue a été remisée on s'est senti obligé
de fermer et maintenant réflexion faite
je sais que ta mère chose qu'on pouvait
faire les affaires allaient pourtant si
bien avant la crise qu un autre
établissement devait ouvrir à
pointe-saint-charles la fermeture des
salles à manger a été fatal si on avait
tenu le coup on a peut-être un quart de
million de dollars de dettes à montréal
966 établissements n'ont pas renouvelé
leur permis de restauration cette année
c'est plus de 15 % des restaurants
qu'ils cessent leur activité
cette proportion est de 13 pour cent
dans l'ensemble du québec
le véritable porteront leur a peut-être
davantage d'années prochain
l'association restauration québec
s'inquiètent certains devront connaître
on était exceptionnel pour maintenir la
tête hors de l'eau
l'industrie est probablement la plus
affectée par la pandémie
avant la crise la coved l'industrie
connaissent ces deux meilleures années
depuis des décennies depuis 30 ans a
fait et pour la première fois les ventes
des restaurants au québec dépassé en
performance toutes les autres provinces
canadiennes c'est pas ouvrir un autre
grumman gaël serve à d'autres projets
d'ici là elle continue de s'impliquer
pour que les restaurateurs soient mieux
soutenus et pour que le personnel soit
mieux payés je regarde mon ancien local
jusqu'alors et je sais qu'il ya des gens
qui l'ont repris je crois que ça va être
un restaurant je leur souhaite beaucoup
de bonheur parce qu'on s'est fait
beaucoup de fun ici beaucoup de plaisir
en vue mais ce ne sont pas les défis qui
manque ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada morrell